hope everybody had a good Memorial Day
weekend coronavirus in popular culture
and in the National Dialogue is no
longer primarily a medical event over
the long weekend that shift has been
completed and what coronavirus now is is
a culture war and this is by necessity
because Donald Trump has failed on
coronavirus from the standpoint of
medical as he might say and the only way
that Donald Trump can plausibly purport
to appear to be winning maybe maybe
is to turn this into a culture war and
he's being assisted in doing that by the
reopen protestors by the anti-vaxxers by
the many others who are actively
contributing to the demise of the United
States the United States being a
laughingstock globally the pandemic is a
disease and it is a disease prevalent
over a whole country or the world that's
what we have in coronavirus we have a
pandemic it is a medical situation the
culture war is a cultural conflict it is
a conflict between groups social groups
typically sometimes economic groups over
values it is a struggle for the
dominance over values and beliefs and
practices and notice that the primary
discussions of coronavirus as a medical
issue have been forced into irrelevance
by this administration it started of
roughly a month ago when I told you that
Donald Trump is getting away from press
briefings and instead doing the CEO
propaganda events these pseudo rallies
at warehouses that distribute PPE I
think he did one last week or the week
before in Pennsylvania I think it was
and to look at this in a different way
to look at it as a culture war explains
a lot of the nonsense that we're seeing
let me give you an example
churches pushed into phase one in a
number of different states as one of the
first types of entities that will reopen
it's indefensible scientifically but
it's a cultural signal
it's a way to signal signal virtue in a
sense and that's why so many governors
have included houses of worship in phase
one they've been under huge pressure to
do it and this is why Donald Trump is
now making a huge deal out of churches
and I'm gonna deal a little bit later
with the legal aspect of Donald Trump
saying he will force governor's to deem
churches essential but that now is a
culture war around coronavirus church
isn't going to church masks masks are
now part of the culture war you wouldn't
have thought of a mask as a political
tool six months ago it is strictly
political now for a huge portion of
American society medical issues have
been relegated to irrelevance
discussions of the are not the
reproduction rate of the virus they're
talking about it in Germany Angela
Merkel is talking about it in Germany as
they look to reopen they talk about it
in New Zealand the contagion treatments
and vaccines these things are being
mentioned by Trump only in the context
of continuing to wage the culture war
and in fact even treatment has become an
opportunity to virtue signal do you
blindly follow Trump on
hydroxychloroquine or do you not
regardless of what the science says this
is by design this is the only way that
Donald Trump can sort of continue to
justify his presidency to justify his
reelection or to even have a shot at
that reelection and this is a movement
that has turned a medical incident into
a culture war the movement understand is
an amalgamation as I wrote on Twitter
yesterday of Trump supporters who just
followed Trump no matter what so-called
libertarians who are just focused on the
so-called Liberty elements which I'll
discuss a little bit later today
anti-vaxxers and conspiracy theorists
there this is a Venn diagram those
groups overlap but they have coalesced
perfectly to pervert the handling of the
pandemic as a pandemic as a medical
incident and instead have turned it into
a cultural war by the way why was Donald
Trump the one briefing Americans from
day one
anyway or Mike Pence or whoever it was
because of the culture war aspect of
this the way to depoliticize a pandemic
is to do what many countries have done
you have doctors do the briefings look
at how Ebola was handled back in 2014 in
some of the outbreak countries in Africa
public health officials were the ones
communicating with the public not
incompetent partisans but this is a
strategy it's a concerted effort and the
Trump administration realizes this is
their only shot so they are actively
escalating the culture war component
every time Trump issues a threat about
overriding governor's those are not
medical statements those are not
constitutional statements he actually
can't do it legally and I'll talk about
that in a moment these are merely claims
from Trump to amp up the culture war and
this reminds me more and more over the
cultural battle over a medical procedure
known as abortion and in fact sometimes
it's been mentioned Trump has even
mentioned there are governors saying
abortion clinics are essential but
churches are not that's red meat culture
war language having Kayleigh Magga nanny
regularly attack the press in briefings
is another culture war component make
this not about the medical facts make it
about fake news and perspective and
point of view Charlotte Klein gave this
example in a really great piece in
Vanity Fair here is Donald Trump's press
secretary attempting to call out a
reporter Jeff Mason from Reuters for
asking whether it's really safe to go
back to church making it a personal
thing where you as an individual don't
like religion take a look at this
president strongly encourage every
governor to allow their churches to
reopen and boy it's interesting to be in
a room that desperately wants to seem to
see these churches and houses of worship
stay close president yet objective
I go to church I'm going to go back to
church the question that we're asking
you and would like to amass the
president and dr. Burke is is it safe
and if it's not because the president
trying to encourage that or the
presentation dr. Burks the people should
we just it is safe to reopen your
churches if you do so in accordance with
the guidelines which are laid out so the
reporter is asking about the safety of
reopening from a medical perspective and
Kaleigh makes it about Wow look at these
leftist loony liberal atheists reporters
who are against religion and the church
component is particularly transparent
with Donald Trump because Donald Trump
has always been faking his supposed
religiosity he's never been religious he
never went to church he was never
against abortion at 68 years old he
decided to run for president suddenly
the Bible's his favorite book he had an
awakening on abortion because he met a
kid he liked where he learned the mom
thought about getting abortion 20 years
prior or however old the kid was but
when he was asked what passages of the
Bible do you like he said that's
personal I'm not going to talk about
that the 2 Corinthians Fiasco
autographing Bibles for people not
exactly showing deference to the sacred
text he was asked are you an old or new
testament guy says both equally
he doesn't care to know anything about
religion religion is merely the perfect
tool to get people who would never
otherwise have voted for Donald Trump
voting for him despite his moral
failings and now it is a huge part of
amplifying the culture war religious
versus non-religious libertarian versus
you know everybody else when religion
would ideally have no place in a
presidential election or in figuring out
what to do about coronavirus ok so
they're fighting this as a cult culture
war what's the damage done by that
that's really the important question the
damage done by fighting this as a
culture war is that it keeps people more
divided than they actually need to be
the anti-vaxxer Bill Gates conspiracy
people are emboldened by this culture
war they'd be mostly on the sidelines if
it weren't for the amplification of the
culture war the more people are
that are angry and divided about
something as empirically definable as a
virus like we know what the virus is
okay we don't know the exact
reproduction rate we their question
marks of course how much contagion is
really happening from surfaces okay but
this is an empirically knowable event
the corona virus they have figured out a
way to get away from the empirical
questions and get to these culture war
type questions and the reason that they
don't want the serious conversations
happening hey how do we reasonably
balance the economy in public health
it's a great question there's a range of
opinions on the left and right they
don't want real conversations happening
between left and right on those on those
issues because they will inevitably be
conversations that lead to the
realization that trump has failed from
day one Trump has to make this a
cultural war we can hope for that the
success he's having making this a
culture war is premature that ultimately
eventually the facts on the ground will
win out but that depends on us that
doesn't depend on him we know what the
strategy is